[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about whatever we want
whatever we want what's up dude we got
David here from Smosh crew how's it
going good
not bad thanks how about yourself
awesome good any people happen to you
last weeks um I've been twitch streaming
more um that's been like a lot of fun do
people throw money at you like here's
600 bucks Damian I mean not sometimes
bucks level but like yeah it's it's I
mean do you play games I do I do either
the hardest possible stuff or the most
relaxing like a Super Nintendo style
indie games so it's either Dark Souls or
like stardew valley where you just run
in a farm and in talk talk about your
feelings actually yeah it's like a
podcast but with the visuals I flip and
love it because I don't know I think
sometimes I think Lily Mars you say
mother flipper - I sent mother flipper
you owe for the best when she's like
social media is like a highlight reel
so I try to be honest with people about
like who I really am like I'm diagnosed
OCD I deal with anxiety stuff all the
time and so sometimes people who are
like Smosh fans end up watching that
they're like no way like me - okay now I
feel more normal you're diagnosed OCD
yeah what kind of [ __ ] you got uh it's
not like a counting [ __ ] we probably got
so much fucked-up [ __ ] but we never been
diagnosed you've got big big like
baseball cards I know you got OCD homey
well I got a DP home what he thinks he's
got Asperger's and I think I did I think
he says he wants hamburgers oh you were
even next to him when he said it and he
goes I think I got Asperger's and then
you're like no you don't and in doing so
JK news day where you kept trying to
prove that you have Asperger's maybe I
did you watch young Sheldon once and
then maybe I have Asperger's and memory
loss but what about OCD do you have I I
do like mental rumination it's called
we're like a one thought gets stuck in
there and it just like revs up like
you're neurotic
you can't stop yeah
long is it like hours like I didn't
sleep much last night it's like one
thing crept in there and I was just like
alright well I'm thinking about the song
isn't that normal it depends I thought
we all toss and turn at night like oh
that [ __ ] I can't believe she said that
[ __ ] to me oh I can't believe it and you
just think about it over and over and
over
sure sure but I think like to maybe a
different level what was it that you
think while moving soon so it was like
one thought about like if there was just
one thing about like there's not enough
space for this one thing and it was just
like oh god that's what I'm gonna be
thinking about constantly no flopping
around although it's Michael its
Microsoft three nights ago I couldn't
sleep because I kept thinking about the
organ trail okay video that's just fun
cuz you just want to wake okay go real
organ oh I was like I can't believe they
walk 2,000 miles what is it like that's
like a long camping trip
oh my god and I started watching
documentaries did research dollars why
are they doing this oh it was for the
gold rush oh man but that [ __ ] best
that's literally probably the biggest
reason why I can't sleep cuz for me the
other day I was looking at cars right
ooh how does it get the Toyota
four-runner don't car finally run it
doesn't have third row seats
no what oh it does military Pro it does
it but that's a slide-out right yeah I
know my car's ooh but the interesting
thing about the four runners that it's
50 grand right which is really high for
a car in that kind of space because
technologically speaking it doesn't even
have like a stock start/stop button it
doesn't even spoke it drive itself or
some [ __ ] like it's a basic [ __ ] at this
money you know what it does do and lasts
forever but those are the cards so
that's the weird part to this highly
cheap utilitarian but it's marked up
this way and for some reason when they
kept it that way and I said did better
in sales so I just kept reading all this
[ __ ] and it end up being [ __ ] like
3:00 a.m. yeah so I was like why the
[ __ ] is it like they know how can be
still like even their key fob is super
old you still have to turn your key and
it's such an old [ __ ] card that
people still [ __ ] love what do you
think I bought the Tacoma and I traded
in a two months
cuz it's too old because they don't none
of Toyota cars like the thing is they're
always not updated you know it's way
behind
they're really expensive for that class
of car yeah but at last
ever yeah that's why people get it end
though and they're like invincible the
struggles man there's something that
keeps us up at night yeah I was getting
mad dude I was getting mad at the Oregon
Trail I was like why don't you guys
bring enough food that's why the Donner
Party [ __ ] probably ate each other
that's the thing you have to start off
as a banker and then you can bring the
most stuff with you all right no I was
saying up really late the other night
because I was watching Casey and I are
watching the favorite and so it's about
Queen and favorite and then and then
like her was Queen him Queen Anne she
was from like the 1600s or something in
Britain okay the Queen and then I
started I I was up really late reading
her whole Wikipedia page she had 17
pregnancies and like none of her kids
survived like the oldest kid was like up
to 11 and then he died suddenly come she
just didn't give up
she's like a breeding dog almost every
year she was pregnant it was crazy but
none of them last
none of them yo back of the day though I
heard kids were dying off like
motherfucks though everyone was I 35 was
like wow the elder of our village yeah
yeah what did I say my great-great
grandma I remember I told you guys my
great-grandma had oh yeah
[ __ ] ton of babies I forgot her nine no
seven thirteen it wasn't even that long
ago I mean it's our parents generation
that's why they popped out so many kids
yeah well my grandma have ten kids
you're they all survived one didn't so
nine yeah your face alright that's why
humans are wired of [ __ ] so much hmm I
bet her like baby was just dying all the
[ __ ] time duty so when they lived up
to a certain age well that's a the
Koreans you guys celebrate the first 100
yeah just [ __ ] die do crepe people
just dial the [ __ ] have you seen
those dead baby for toe photos yeah like
in the Great Depression you know not
they're done like yeah they're like
stressed up dead kids and dead babies
and until with dress them up and then
they'll be in family photo oh yeah
just dead relatives doesn't matter oh
yeah they would do for dead relatives -
yes I'm Caribbean [ __ ] good
psychological nightmare right there
they're trying to let me pose grandma
like yeah I know all right
but that was part of like the culture
back then it was just like hey we still
there's still part of the family
stop crying we have to take the photo
stop crying
drama you're leaking oh my god dude
that's so [ __ ] weird man
that is weird I'm weird no maybe not
nevermind well you can't stop in case
Charlie you could talk about whatever
you because this might be controversial
I don't know okay so last night I was
when I was researching an article you
committed a crime I didn't commit a
crime I came across this vice video it
was like a 20 minute video and how they
were exploring like how interesting it
is that within the Muslim community the
highest growing like race letters
joining Muslims is Mexican I was gonna
watch that video I was like whoa that's
insane like that's so cool because every
time anyone talks about politics or
religion or race or sex it's just you
don't talk about religion at the dinner
table you're not talking about religion
you're talking about a vice documentary
your Tamil people joining yeah and in
the document or nothing about the
religion itself or its value okay so
what or what about this what about it
nothing yours just something interesting
I came across recently that makes sense
Mexicans look like Middle Eastern people
they're both brown why wouldn't people
also a lot of words are shared Mexican
Muslim it just sounds nice and they have
the only Spanish mosque in like the
world is in Houston and then in Houston
they have like the highest population of
Mexican well I can't wait to see a
[ __ ] cholo Muslim dude that'd be
[ __ ] oh yeah
in that vice video there were two the
guy that started it seemed like they
were kind of sort of like in that world
that's [ __ ] you pull out the Raiders
towel
got about to the mecca a fool did you
wake up and do your [ __ ] deals at
briars fool
ah [ __ ] it I can't eat am [ __ ]
fasting this one graver Ramadan again
man Ramadan oh okay no so one of the
guys that they interviewed he was an
immigrant from Mexico he was like under
daca thing and everything and then so
when he was converting to become a
Muslim his mom was so against it and she
was just like how could you cuz you know
there's this misconception of that
religion it and then so it was so messed
up because she would sneak pork and the
bean pies India cuz her her should all
be doing it out of love I know but you
gotta respect their beliefs and hearing
so you can yeah but I mean that's like
sending your kids to like gay conversion
camp in shape because they don't want
you to be you know like that's like this
act that stream that's like this let's
say my mom's like oh you know what my
new religions gonna be Chuck free and
I'm like what man [ __ ] I put cocaine
in her teeth doesn't kill you you know
there's no negative side effect right
mom you reorganized your space six times
everything looks correct yeah well I see
that [ __ ] now no yeah but then at the
end of it though the mom she also became
love she was like I gave my son such a
hard time
but you know the culture is not that
different because Spain was once a
pretty much Muslim nation because the
Moors right control it and in so you
know Spanish people have a lot of you
know that kind of culture within it even
though it became Catholic way do you see
it in the architecture you can see in
the words the Moors with that it was
like a nation of Muslim nation I guess
so it's like it was like a group like it
was like saying like the Turkish Empire
or whatever it was like an empire but
the Spanish guitar is it really even
from Spain
it's from the Morse and like Arabic fur
pants is a bunt alone and then
pantalones yes that's also Morocco look
at your [ __ ] face there like a half
North African nation okay that they came
in and yeah I'm asking honest I didn't
know how was this like all connection
yeah III don't know if Morocco is there
there's their main state or where they
came from but they were once like a big
Empire and did you know that coffee is
an Arabic drink and we all drink it so
we're all it'll be a Muslim massage with
it anyway so they have that the Spanish
culture and they exported that to the
Mexicans and then so it's like a mystery
right so few things yeah if you mix if
you mix with that then it's like you
kinda you couldn't have it in the
Spanish bullet anybody who didn't grow
up like Muslim and they convert to like
the Muslim religion you got hardcore
they got some [ __ ] dedication in that
religion dude cuz if I was looking for a
religion and I was just going through a
list and okay this is what you have to
do as a Muslim what's the easiest one
that's what I'll be living at hug I say
the easiest one is one with at least
amount of rules series around the Getty
for Ian spaghetti papaya the barrio
Fayed no we have to change the spaghetti
far
way better yeah because I Muslim
religion man that's some high dedication
do they make Christian people look like
[ __ ] yeah could you be by yo man just
pray before I eat [ __ ] be wake
up for the sunset yeah son son [ __ ] son
they go down to they [ __ ] pray on the
[ __ ] knees and [ __ ] son that's wild I
really want to counter of how many times
David Kirsten why son
you know this [ __ ] tight dude like my
so my uncle we used to he used to own a
t-shirt shop at the flea markets so he
should sell those [ __ ] ghetto ass
t-shirts all the homies used to wear
[ __ ] you know like ten for like two
dollars type of [ __ ] smell the custard
stick out to me yes the cheapest [ __ ]
[ __ ] out [ __ ] so and so the dude
next to us was a guy that used to sell a
[ __ ] person drugs and [ __ ] but he
would wake up every morning and he would
do his prayers without [ __ ] fail yeah
since we remained that's a that's a part
of what they got it that's the
dedication that I saw and I remember cuz
you know we grew up in a Christian
household and we would just pray I would
just pray right before I eat there got
thanks for this [ __ ] banana eat it
and that's about it I'm like yo this guy
he goes in dude makes me look like [ __ ]
you know one of the most um bipolar
religions out there is Buddhism hmm
because this is a religion accepting of
all religions no it's like it's kind of
like it's all like peaceful and [ __ ] on
one end but then the other part is like
it's so painful it's like you want to
achieve enlightenment through pain I
just know the other part what's the
people I mean like why can't you how can
you sit still for five hours straight
without talking to anybody like how can
you wake up at 4 a.m. and instead still
walk well another [ __ ] mom comes in
and whips you in your [ __ ] back and
you go and meditate under a waterfall
that sub-zero temperature and [ __ ] like
why would you do these things to
yourself to and to reach this level of
enlightenment to listen a hardcore
Buddhism like legit Buddhism is [ __ ]
tough like real [ __ ] Buddhism it's
like why yeah hey you know what I tried
you know what I tried recently but I
didn't work for me goes out
I mean know I'm guilty of it because I
get it because it's like we do it
through martial arts right they have
aspect of a lot of Zen Buddhism and
stuff like that but I don't know why I'm
doing it and I'm doing I mean it's in
your genes pearls I know that's why I
want to do it because it's in my heart
to do it but when I'm doing I'm like why
ocean I feel so much better that's how I
feel about running you know my mom does
like a hundred and eight Buddhist
burpees like in the morning it's just a
burpee but you're like fine with
everything till she prays right up right
like a Buddhist prayer the way my mom
does it you start here then you got to
go all the way down like this and he put
your head on the floor and then you flip
your palms over and you got to get back
up right and she does it takes like 30
minutes I'm saying that's the start of
the prayer Wow
initiating chants these [ __ ] mantras
and shift like two hours how many that's
why I don't get I'm like I'm like why
why do I have to put myself in so much
pain and then you feel better it's like
a massage when you get [ __ ] up and
then afterwards you feel good you
pretend there's a light in your [ __ ]
toe and then you [ __ ] travel it to
the other toes to help you follow us to
meditate and stuff I don't work I'm like
I haven't read that one it's like you
focus on a tote her like a scan well
whatever that metaphor is it could be a
light or whatever but you focus on a toe
then whatever happens there then you
focus on the next toe than the next toe
and the next toe oh and they're supposed
to help you relax and meditate that [ __ ]
does not [ __ ] work it does not work
cuz I picture this light and for some
reason that light won't turn on and I
get frustrated and my toes a light bulb
that just is broken so just that one
blinking Christmas light this but I know
it's you in this whole line of the month
all I see it you're supposed to picture
it just light up every time and it
doesn't like I don't know if I'm not
good at meditation or some [ __ ] but that
light bulb is my toe and it just won't
turn on the [ __ ] you switch like this
pissing me off but it keeps me awake
I do the obvious I try to stay awake and
I can't we're like trying to watch TV
I'm like
stay away stay away and I actually met
it take to go to sleep because it makes
me fall asleep but then every time I try
to focus on that like I try to focus on
the scanning right you know if you fall
asleep though you're failing our
meditation for sure you're supposed to
be awake but have minimal thoughts yeah
so for me though like I'm trying to scan
right I'm trying to focus yeah my whole
body I start from my toes and I go up
but then out of nowhere it's kind of
like the like that concentration it's
like a cloud and you just kind of go
like this and it just disintegrates and
now I'm thinking about something else
now you're in a dream so my [ __ ] I can't
get to that point that's what I'm trying
to get into right so I'm trying to take
my mind into that state where it husband
you drift off and do a dream world I
can't get there it's so [ __ ] hard and
it's not necessarily that it's like
you're completely aware but you're empty
in your mind so you you you observe
everything that's happening but you're
not letting your mind get distracted and
going into a dream world or anything
you're just totally aware and being in
the present so if you do get into this
mindset or like mind state where you're
like thinking or dreaming or doing
something else then you're actually not
doing the purpose of meditation which is
to be completely aware of what's going
on in them and say it's a muscle you
have to exercise it get better at it but
it's but it helps with your dumb as [ __ ]
because your minds been empty you would
think it's so hard to that's just so
[ __ ] difficult man because I guess it
is true right you do have to practice
that muscle constantly over and over and
over but I can't get past the first toe
try the you try the like 3rd eye thing
where you like close your eye and if you
imagine like a third eye like out here
and up a little bit you might actually
use your eyes to look up and because
you're concentrating on that muscle and
because it's such a weird like thing to
be doing yeah I can't really think about
anything else and then failing that
melatonin and then you go to sleep cuz
you're focusing Carville colors the eye
whose eye is it George Clooney's eye
it's definitely George cleaners eye it's
a big old George Clooney eye and he's
just like I got my start where the one
line or on a sitcom you're like wow and
then you're thinking about that and
that's meditation I think the word focus
though it creates this fun work feeling
mm-hmm
if people get tense on an area right I'm
gonna but the point is just to relax the
point is just to empty everything and
just float in like
relax and just I don't know like let the
wind hit you and pass you by you know
what how do you do I did you just have
Muriel stay awake and talk to me about a
day then I could just blink out like I
do my mouth be open sometime just like
this I love you ash you're so [ __ ]
hard man meditation is not easy dude
they make it look so [ __ ] easy in all
those videos where they just sit there I
wonder if they're just bullshitting some
yeah cuz I I swear they're [ __ ]
asleep you know I used to go to those
things with my mom all the time right
what are you like try to be a monk like
eight hours and when you're a kid like
I'm like man it's just [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I would legit see like a row of 50
people there'd be like [ __ ] Hodge and
my sister like grandma's oh my how the
[ __ ] am I supposed to do this if that
[ __ ] is about to fall asleep death was
about to policy no they're just in a
trance I extend Mariel didn't know how
big Edie I was because I didn't know how
fidgety I was either until I lost no
weight cuz all the way kept me down so
because I was so fat I just never wanted
to move but I lost the weight I can't
stop [ __ ] digital now I can stop
touching [ __ ] I can't stop moving she
goes you're so [ __ ] annoying awesome
what do you want me to do man like what
do you want me I'm so light now like
she's gotta [ __ ] move
[Music]